moving on to the man accused of building
the bomb that blew up Pan Am flight 103
over Lockerbie Scotland he's faced
people who lost loved ones in that
attack for the first time Abu agile
Mohammed Masood appeared in federal
court in Washington yesterday facing
charges for the first time in the 1988
bombing killed 270 people including 190
Americans senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is in
Washington for us following all this
Catherine good morning Good morning Tony
the federal judge read massoud his
rights and the terrorism charges which
include the destruction of an aircraft
causing death if convicted prosecutors
said they will not seek a death sentence
because the crimes did not carry that
penalty when the plane was bombed more
than three decades ago
the alleged bomber refused to answer
questions until he could retain his own
attorney slowing down the legal process
the families have waited 34 years to
witness it's incredibly satisfying
Stephanie Bernstein was in court for her
late husband Michael a justice
department Nazi war crimes investigator
who took Pan Am flight 103 returning
from a European business trip she
learned that Masood was in U.S custody
early Sunday morning I felt that I was I
was dreaming because I had been sleeping
when I got the call so the fact that he
was in U.S custody that he was on the
way to the United States was was surreal
but very gratifying in a statement
attorney general Merrick Garland said
masseuse trial in an American court is
an important step forward in our mission
to honor the victims and pursue Justice
on behalf of their loved ones two years
ago the justice department announced
charges against massoud after an
international team of investigators
pieced together fragments of the jet
scattered over the countryside in
Southwest Scott It ultimately led to
parts of a cassette recorder packed with
explosives officials have yet to reveal
how massoud came into U.S custody now
but it was a welcome development for
victims families it was the first time
that I was hopeful I wasn't sure if you
know within my lifetime we would be able
to see the day before the hearing
Victoria comic held a news conference in
South Florida her husband was also among
the 190 Americans killed on the flight
it's the victim's family's fervent wish
that U.S criminal trial proceedings
begin immediately
Justice delayed is Justice denied
next week the court will consider
massoud's legal representation he will
be held in a Virginia jail pending A
detention hearing on December 27th if
convicted he could face a penalty of
Life imprison Nate
Catherine thank you